at this altitude I can run flat out for
my hands this episode is brought to you
by Vimeo specifically a new offering
called Vimeo business I've done a lot of
collaboration with these guys
Vimeo business has all of the prior
benefits of Vimeo Pro including VIP
support whether you make videos for a
living
run your own company like yours truly or
simply want to amp up your video
marketing video business is here to help
they have more than 280 million creators
and viewers worldwide and Vimeo business
makes it easier to share your videos
with a global audience and connect with
professional video makers to bring your
stories to life so if you need
assistance it's there you can also
upload up to 5 terabytes and store your
videos in one secure place you can add
up to 10 team members to your account
for easy collaboration and gather
feedback with seamless review tools you
can add clickable calls to action and
perhaps most interesting to me capture
email addresses directly in the player
this can help you generate leads and
drive conversion for whatever you are
trying to optimize say for a newsletter
or in fact a sales page of some type
video business helps you optimize your
videos by tracking viewer engagement and
drop-off so you can then modify your
approach or creative moving forward and
improve it and it connects to Google
Analytics for even more insights let's
check it out go to Vimeo comm forward
slash Tim 10 to save 10% on Vimeo
business that's vimeo.com / TI m10
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show it's because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
hello my caribou and capricorns this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show this
episode is a repeat guest one of the
most popular dr. Dominic Dom D'Agostino
known as Dom of course Twitter you can
find him at Dominic de Agosti - that is
Dominic da Jie OST I the number two he
is an associate professor in the
department of molecular pharmacology and
physiology at the University of South
Florida Missoni
College of Medicine and a senior
research scientist at the Institute for
human and machine cognition IHMC which
also had a great treatment in the
current issue of outside magazine on
which there's a clown who looks a lot
like me he has also dead lifted 500
pounds for 10 reps after a 7 day fast
he's a beast also a good friend of dr.
Peter Atia who has also been on this
podcast the primary focus of Dom's
laboratory is developing and testing
metabolic therapies including ketogenic
diets ketone esters and ketones
supplements to induce nutritional or
therapeutic ketosis and low toxicity
metabolic based drugs that's a mouthful
Hey
much of his work is related to metabolic
therapies and nutritional strategies for
peak performance and resilience in
extreme environments this is where I get
very interested I recently went up to
altitude and used exogenous not
androgynous exogenous ketones to help me
acclimate and function at high altitude
but it also works in the opposite
direction under water for instance both
related to hypoxia his research is
therefore supported by among others the
Office of Naval Research the Department
of Defense and other private
organizations and foundations in this
part 3 Dom
been on twice before Dom focuses on
disease prevention cancer and more
mastery of the ketogenic diet so as I
always say without further ado please
enjoy this tutorial and master class
with Dominic
D'Agostino ok I covered the ketogenic
diet and I cover questions about
exogenous ketones and that took about
two hours so now I'm going into cancer
research questions or just questions in
general about cancer so the first one I
like to address I've gotten many emails
about this you seen a few questions on
Facebook does a ketogenic diet be chemo
for for all cancers and I would say
absolutely not but and that does not
mean that it should not be used as an
adjuvant or support for various cancer
therapies that are out there a number of
situations where the ketogenic diet may
not be the preferred therapy for most
cancers I would say Leukemia Lymphoma is
Hodgkin's lymphoma thyroid cancer
testicular cancer if caught early
prostate cancer melanoma breast cancer
all these cancers can be effectively
treated with chemotherapy or radiation
in some cases and also uh brain brain
tumors if it's if it's class one or two
tumor that's not our grade one and two
it's not very metastatic and it's more
localized than surgery radiation chemo
can be very effective we focus on
cancers that are not really treated
effectively with the standard of care
brain tumors grade four would be a
glioblastoma cancer it's highly invasive
highly aggressive sort of has the
metabolic phenotype we say that that
expresses the orbit effect so it's very
glycolytic so the name glioblastoma
multiforme it's comprised of very very
diverse heterogenous
of cells that are resistant to therapy
and it's genetically very heterogenous
metabolically probably much more
homogeneous in regards to being able to
target it from a metabolic standpoint so
we focus on you know this aggressive
metastatic cancer and green tumors in
our lab and we think the standard of
care we know that it does very little we
do feel that the ketogenic diet when
properly administered can dramatically
enhance the efficacy of standard of care
so even though the standard of care may
not buy much time for a patient with
glioblastoma we think that we could
dramatically enhance the efficacy and
maybe reduce the side effects of a
standard of care with the ketogenic diet
or may be combined with intermittent
fasting I think I would recommend
looking at the work of dr. Adrian check
and she's at Barrow Neurological
Institute and she's done some studies
with a preclinical mouse model of
glioblastoma and that work has inspired
a clinical trial that's now recruiting
patients to use the ketogenic diet
combined with standard care which would
be Timmons Olamide and radiation and her
work is really remarkable in that it
shows the the ketogenic diet
dramatically enhances the efficacy of
radiation therapy and it does that
through a number of different mechanisms
that she's looking at I think most
importantly to highlight if we kind of
look at the the sum of all her work
which is a incredible body of work that
that she's done she was working on this
long before I came into the field I was
directed to her by dr. John Rowe who is
probably the leading ketogenic diet
researcher
sure Pediatrics and Calgary now but he
was at Barrow Neurological Institute and
I contacted him and he directed me to
Adrian checks worked and it really blew
me away she shows the the effect of the
diet can be dramatically enhanced with
radiation so I was kind of a pretty
critical of radiation therapy for cancer
especially for glioblastoma for various
reasons but when looking at Adrian's
work and just hearing from you know
feedback from patients my thoughts on
radiation therapy have softened a bit
and in the context of radiation therapy
given with ketogenic diet
it appears that nutritional ketosis
enhances the tumor killing effect of
radiation and it does that through a
number of different mechanisms probably
crippling or reducing glycolytic flux
through the tumors which would impact
their antioxidant and Dodgers
antioxidant status by reducing things
like the pentose phosphate pathway which
helps the cell regenerate glutathione so
if and we know that the efficacy of the
radiation therapy really results from
generating oxygen free radicals in the
tumor tissue and tumor cells are already
at an elevated state of oxidative stress
so further stimulating reactive oxygen
species production with the damaging
effects of radiation can put them over
the edge and be very destructive
so the key Jenk diet seems to enhance
that process and simultaneously the
ketones
tend to lower inflammation and the
normal healthy tissue and protect your
normal healthy brain tissue we think
that there's a lot of potential for the
ketogenic diet as an adjuvant for all
our studies we've always used the
ketogenic diet
as one piece of a combined metabolic
therapy approach so the ketogenic diet
is an adjuvant to you know
hyperbaric oxygen that we've used and
now we're looking at you know ketone
supplementation and combining that with
hyperbaric oxygen so the ketone
supplements tend to further augment the
therapeutic efficacy of the ketogenic
diet by lowering blood glucose and
elevating blood ketone levels that
therapeutic zone that Tom Seifert cost
the metabolic zone the glucose ketone
index is simply the the ketones the
glucose by the ketones the index of let
me see one or two really an index of one
is what you want to shoot for and when
you achieve that an index one you
essentially get a blood glucose level
that's in blood ketone level that are
essentially the same
so like 3.5 million where a level of
glucose and ketones that a person could
sustain and would be sort of
physiologically optimized he has a paper
on that nutrition and metabolism
describing the glucose ketone index and
that has been thought to be sort of the
optimal therapeutic zone for person
patient using the ketogenic diet to
manage their cancer or combining it with
the standard of care so it makes sense
to use a metabolic based approach on
tumors that have a Warburg phenotype so
tumors that are highly glycolytic which
include about 80 to 90 percent of
cancers and the cancers that tend not to
be the ones that are more glycolytic are
also the ones that you don't have to
worry so much about these are ones
cancer cells that generally are not very
invasive or aggressive in regards to
growth the ones that are not glycolytic
so cancer cells for example that
wouldn't show up on a PET scan and that
would be like prostate cancer for
example
yeah the ketogenic diet does not be
chemo its
we know that chemo can be effective for
a number of different cancers and if
caught early sort of a growing list of
different types of cancers Randy Metcalf
asked the question after listening to
his chat on dr. Rhonda Patrick's show I
want to know more about the detoxifying
effects of ketosis on tree cancer cells
and on healthy individuals and how does
one jumpstart daily ketogenic cycle
without supplements and how can you
maintain lean muscle mass when fasting
so number of questions there as I
mentioned I'll kind of talk about refer
back to the metabolic zone achieving the
metabolic zone a glucose ketone index of
one or two so Google the glucose ketone
index and download that paper and
nutrition metabolism it's open access
and kind of gives you a description of
where you have to be when you do fasting
or the ketogenic diet and I think if you
achieve that zone I think that then you
do that two or three times a year that
could be very therapeutic in regards to
cancer prevention really effective at
targeting sort of precancerous cells and
maybe even jump-starting your immune
system making your immune system maybe
more hyper vigilant against the cancer
cells that you already have so as far as
jump-starting your body into ketosis you
could use exogenously tones okay without
supplements just jump starting can be
done with exercise
I wouldn't recommend vigorous exercise I
would recommend you know a walk two to
three hour walk for example you might
want to preface that with a short
high-intensity 10-15 minutes or
something to just kind of activate your
sympathetic nervous system but not too
much do some you know push-ups chin-ups
a little bit of a few sprints I believe
that when you activate your sympathetic
nervous system mobilize a lot of free
fatty acids for
you'll and set your body up for a more
effective fat earning and more effective
transition into ketosis when you do kind
of a a low a low-impact walk don't a lot
of testing on myself of glucose and
ketone levels in different scenarios and
that seems to work really well I did
that yesterday actually so fasting can
stimulate al-tofah G and perhaps you
make the immune system sort of more more
hyper vigilant against cancer and
pre-cancer cells I mentioned but you
need to acknowledge that if you fast too
long or you calorie restrict too long
that can suppress your immune system
let me see lean body mass so there's a
couple ways to get around the loss of
lean body mass that's going to happen
who's you know you have to realize that
you're losing a lot of water when you do
when you do it faster your weight may go
down but a lot of its going to be water
weight you could probably mitigate some
of the muscle loss with branched chain
amino acids then I would buy just a pure
branched chain amino acid product is
just branching amino acids and nothing
else
consume that sort of if you're going to
continue doing any form of exercise I
wouldn't recommend doing you know
high-intensity exercise if you're
fasting but if you do do any exercise to
take your branch chain amino acids
before and maybe during it's important I
always emphasize this when people talk
about you know wasting away when you
renew fast and George Cahill's work at
Harvard shows that the physiological
shift that occurs when you're fasting
when you enter a state a fasting ketosis
functions to have a really profound
protein sparing effect so your brain is
a highly metabolic organ and it's going
it's a big glucose sink and when you
elevate ketones that prevents a lot of
the gluconeogenic amino acids from being
broken down the skeletal muscle so it's
very protein sparing
that regards so otherwise right if we
fasted we would rapidly waste away
probably within you know less than two
weeks but there's reports of people
fasting there's a guy that's 500 pounds
at fasted for over a year and and there
was no no major ill effects reported
from that and you fast it down to 190
pounds some of the helpful supplements
that I think utilize during a fast would
be like I mentioned branched chain amino
acids my good friend lien Norton did his
PhD on leucine and did it in the lab
with Donald Lehman so if you're
interested in kind of understanding
anabolic or anti catabolic effects of
branched chain amino acids going to
pubmed and look up Lee Norton studies on
leucine you know I've experimented with
a few things I think the serotonin
precursor 5-htp can be beneficial if
we're taking in branched chain amino
acids we're actually limiting the
transport of tryptophane across the
blood-brain barrier because it competes
I tend to get the munchies at night so
my appetite gets really high at night
time when I was doing when I was fasting
and I found that and I fasted too with
with branched chain amino acids but I
think a supplement like 5htp at night
may be able to to reduce some of the
hunger cravings and also help put you to
sleep so if I'm hungry I find it found
it kind of hard to sleep after a while
that my body adapted to it so so that
product ketones MCT oil and MCT oil
powder may be helpful but not absolutely
necessary there's a book out there
called the fasting cure by Upton
Sinclair and you just googled the
fasting cure and Sinclair you'll find it
and it's a free PDF to download and it's
a fascinating little book that just
talks about the benefits of fasting
so next question is Lowell Kubek
and he asked in addition to an update on
ketosis effects on cancer is there any
updates with ketosis affecting
chemotherapy recovery what types of
cancers does ketosis have the largest
impact on so I kind of answered that
already managing brain tumors and
metastatic cancer I would say would be
at the top of the list and as I
mentioned as an adjuvant to chemo and
radiation see Adrienne checks work at
Barrow Neurological Institute her
preclinical work and also an ongoing
clinical trial and I would also
encourage anyone you know who's really
passionate about seeing this transition
into the patient population if you know
if they're interested they could support
Adrienne checks work at Barrow it's it's
difficult to get funding for these types
of studies and I know sort of the
project was stopped and started because
because of funding and I don't think
it's a lot of money either so if you
look up Adrienne checks work and maybe
she may have some kind of donation link
there I'm not sure she does but but it
would be great for people listening to
support her work in that clinical trial
because there's sort of a lot riding on
that trial the research is being
conducted in a way that really fits the
the criteria we think is important so
we're being assured that the patients
are actually in ketosis and they're
monitored and recorded in ways that'll
help really get questions answered the
clinical trials in progress right now so
they're continuing to recruit more
patients most effective for targeting
cancer this warburg phenotype and that
would be like 80 to 90 percent of of
cancers we'll have an increase in will
demonstrate high intensity on
fluorodeoxyglucose PET scan
and these are the cancer cells that are
more glycolytic are also the ones that
are going to be more invasive and more
deadly and they're the ones that so are
growing more rapidly so as they're
consuming more glucose that glucose is
shuttled to not only energy but also the
biomass of the tumor so when you're
imaging the cancer cells lighting up
that's really they're shuttling all that
glucose to increase the biomass of the
tumor and when you look at like a cancer
or prostate cancer where it's not
lighting up it's growing so slow that
it's it's not really it's glucose
demands are not that high so in many
cases it's probably just better left
alone you know when when people are
diagnosed with having a tumor they kind
of think about it as like this alien
that needs to be chopped out of the body
and with slash-and-burn techniques but
there's many autopsies those reading a
number of books and papers on this
there's many autopsies have been done on
people that die from completely
unrelated causes that are full of tumors
that had you know that have tumors and
absolutely no problems at all so they
may have lived you know many years if
not decades with with tumors and had no
problems at all so if you're diagnosed
and you know that's why it's just
watching and waiting isn't as important
thing so that's we can live you know
with cancer many types of tumors with
with no problem dr. fine dr. Fineman I
believe did some work in vitro on
multiple different cancer types
with ketones and showed that the the
gist of their work was that a large
majority of cancer cells cannot
effectively use ketones for energy so
that that goes across multiple different
cancer cell lines and I know dr. Brent
Reynolds he's doing work at University
of Florida
bill he'd send work preclinical work on
colon cancer breast cancer in
glioblastoma and some of the
glioblastoma cells were taken from
patients who uses it
they use patient-derived xenograft I
think most importantly it's like the
evidence points to this being the
ketogenic diet is doing no harm right do
you no harm therapy so we know through
at least two or three to pilot trials
that the qje diet is well tolerated we
know from the epilepsy community that
the Kijang diet you know very well
tolerated I think it was Melanie Schmidt
that did work on the title paper was the
effects of the ketogenic diet on the
quality of life of sixteen patients with
advanced cancer a pilot trial so of
those that completed the diet for three
months of treatment there were patients
with ovarian breast sarcoma osteosarcoma
esophageal cancer pancreatic cancer
thyroid colon endometrial lung and
stomach cancers so a variety of
different cancers there was an improved
quality of life
and there was no sort of major adverse
effects on various blood parameters and
the side effects reported were really
minimal so they were kind of like
temporary constipation and fatigue
there's a lot of good evidence already
that the occasional diet can work on a
variety of different cancers we need
more study some of those studies are in
progress so I'm going to transition now
to random questions here so Scott shear
asks I know Scott it's got talk to talk
about ketosis and hyperbaric oxygen
therapy how why and when so it's a good
question and I think it's going to vary
depending upon the individual and I
think
generally younger patients can tolerate
more hyperbaric oxygen and get benefits
from it
so with hyperbaric oxygen therapy you
get the immediate benefits from hyper
oxygenating the area that you're trying
to treat right whether that be an
ischemic wound you're trying to reverse
tumour hypoxia and saturate a tumor with
oxygen to stimulate oxidative stress
right in apoptosis and in the womb in
the in the cancer which is much like a
wound actually so you have that effect
if someone has a brain tumor they're
going to be more susceptible to CNS
oxygen toxicity so you want to start
them really lower like you know 1.5
atmospheres of oxygen and do that for
you know 45 to 60 minutes and then work
up from there so the protocol that we
used in our preclinical model was 2.5
atmospheres of oxygen three times a week
and that varies from what's used for
wound healing which is kind of Monday
Wednesday Friday
Monday through Friday at five times a
week like two atmospheres of oxygen so
it really depends on kind of who you're
treating what you're treating and the
approved therapies for hyperbaric oxygen
there's like 14 different fda-approved
and you have air and gas embolism the
bone infections
osteomyelitis burns carbon monoxide
poisoning so you want to use some
maximum concentration of oxygen to get
the to push that carbon dioxide off of
the off of the even Bowden molecule and
it's also occupying like you know
cytochrome for the electron transport
chain just causing tissue hypoxia so you
want it you want the maximum amount of
of oxygen for that or tolerable certain
types of bringing or sinus infections
decompression sickness
so this is sort of gas gangrene is
another that's an anaerobic bacteria so
hyper oxygenating it can help to kill it
necrotizing soft tissue infections
radiation injury for example damage from
radiation therapy for cancer can be
effectively treated with hyperbaric
oxygen therapy skin grafts and wounds
that have not healed with other
treatments for example treating like a
foot ulcer or someone with diabetes or
very bad circulation the wound healing
process is enhanced by increasing tissue
perfusion and are increasing the oxygen
content you know within the actual
tissue lowering reactive oxygen species
so which is kind of a secondary effect
and lowering inflammation so when it
comes to cancer so that would be an
off-label use the non FDA approved use
of hyperbaric oxygen if you're not
getting radiation therapy and I would
ask you just look at some of the
research that my colleague research
associate dr. Angela Poth was first
author on a number of manuscripts if you
just google ketogenic diet and
hyperbaric oxygen so we have a number of
manuscripts that are open access and
then are downloadable that describes the
use of this approach the combination of
nutritional ketosis with a diet or
supplemented ketogenic diet with
hyperbaric oxygen we think that this
combination is not only effective but
nutritional ketosis will enhance the
safety and the efficacy of hyperbaric
oxygen by preventing the potential of
CNS oxygen toxicity seizures so the
limitation of a Navy SEAL diver is CNS
oxygen toxicity the limitation
of therapeutic potential of hyperbaric
oxygen therapy is the the limitation of
the dose to avoid CNS oxygen toxicity so
we can more safely use a higher dose of
hyperbaric oxygen therapy and sort of
blast the tumor with high levels of
oxygen and oxidative stress we could do
that more safely in the context of
getting the patient into nutritional
ketosis
and we think that nutritional ketosis
will [ __ ] the antioxidant defenses of
the highly glycolytic tumor cells that
rely pretty heavily on the pentose
phosphate pathway or shunt to generate
the reduced intermediates and to
actually generate the glutathione reduce
glutathione in the cell so that sort of
process is limited or crippled when a
patient is achieving that metabolic zone
and so the hyperbaric oxygen therapy
would work much more effectively next
question
Justin Bowman how long would an amateur
endurance athlete need to be in ketosis
to get the full benefit of being fat
adapted for a marathon and what would
you recommend as a supplement stack to
fuel a marathon for example MCT powder
combined with map essential amino acids
sodium and some form of electrolyte
every hour so question mark good
question and it's one that I get often
so I included in here Ben Greenfield has
spoken pretty extensively on intro race
supplementation any ketone supplement
that you use during race you want to
make sure that you've tested that pretty
thoroughly before you actually use it
you know you've tested it through your
training extensively and titrated it up
to the point where you start to get GI
stress so you want to make sure
you know what kind of dosas you can
tolerate before you start using it
intro race for inter a supplementation
we've done some experiments in the lab
and I've done experiments of myself and
the pure caprylic triglyceride or the c8
may be the best alternative to medium
chain triglycerides which is a
combination of the c8 and c10 so the
longer so that would be that would be
helpful supplementation branched chain
amino acids I think are really helpful
other than that I think you know as your
preparation is really what's going to be
most important is that you're adapted to
earning those fuels and the longer
you're on a ketogenic diet or key to
adapt that the more benefits you're
going to derive from it and the easier
it gets to so this may take months or
even years to get fully optimized to the
ketogenic diet so when you switch fuel
sources your body your body's physiology
doesn't automatically you know switch
over so there's a lot of complicated
things happening from an upregulation of
the transporters various enzyme systems
liver metabolism gene expression for
these to be fully manifested it's going
to take some time it's going to take a
significant amount of time to be fully
fully optimal and from the the really
advanced athletes that have communicated
with me they said it took about a half a
year for them to sort of get their
stride on ketogenic diet so I would say
just keep that in mind Johnny uh Bala
mer asked this is the question I get
often should in a pony for carrier be
careful with the ketogenic diet it's a
great question so interestingly the
study that was done by Sam Henderson
which looked at the effects of an MCT
oil based product and
time it was called Acey 1202 they looked
at at patients with mild cognitive
impairment and found that the the
patient population that was a pony for
positive did not respond as favorably at
least to medium chain triglycerides
supplementation in regards to
enhancement of cognitive performance and
they had a mild very modest boost in
beta-hydroxybutyrate I direct your
listeners tend to the IHMC stem talk it
was episode 12 with dr. Dale Bredesen
and discusses his topic fairly at that
length and you know covers a lot of
things that I was interested in as far
as what signaling effects apoe4 sort of
is manifested in the brain and how we
can target that you know actionable
things that we can do as individuals to
mitigate some of the effects of being
able before positive and we know that
apoe4
seems to play seems to influence NF
kappa-b signaling so the issue is that
apoe4 enhances the pro-inflammatory
effects of NF kappa-b intends to reduce
the the activation of cert one so if we
think about what the what the ketogenic
diet does and you can apply this to
calorie restriction and intermittent
fasting to the metabolic and signaling
effects nutritional ketosis would be
favorable to those with a bowi for you I
would emphasize the that not just an MCT
based supplement which was done the
Henderson study using AC 1202 which is
published years back but actual
carbohydrate restriction associated with
nutritional ketosis
you know inflammation is really the
driver here from from how I understand
it you know nutritional ketosis
intermittent fasting all these things
activate pathways that are down
regulated by having this beneficial
pathways that are down regulated by
having this genotype and it also doesn't
silence but it attenuates a lot of the
pro-inflammatory pathways that are
associated with with being able to be
for positive so you know having this
April before genes these carriers would
have a survival advantage in in several
different situations so the negative
effects of being an a bogie for carrier
really happen later in life so as we age
it'll be more important to follow
nutritional ketosis and perhaps
intermittent fasting protocol you know
exercise we know exercise increases BDNF
intermittent fasting intermittent
dietary restriction so even if you're
not fasting you know do calorie
restriction strength training so
strength training is going to build the
lean body mass that functions in glucose
disposal so other supplements that may
help individuals that are apt for would
be bergeron and maybe metformin - i
think we need to study that I don't know
if there's any it seem like an obvious
thing to do kind of a study on those
that are April before positive and the
effects of metformin so I know there's
quite a few individuals out there I look
on clinical trials that go to see if
that's Matthew maverick has a question
regarding cheat meals any downside to
kicking out of ketosis for an occasional
cheat meal or does one need long-term
sustained ketosis to get the benefits
I found that I can get back relatively
fast especially if I run the next day
that's what he said so so there's no
downside unless you are using it to
manage a disease process right so Andrew
Scarborough talked about having brain
tumor listen to his podcast yesterday so
definitely recommend your readers look
up the podcasts I think it's
unquantified quantified body by andrew
scarborough who has like a grade three
brain tumor and he's using the ketogenic
diet and an interesting sort of list of
supplements and foods to manage his
brain tumor above and beyond what he
said was was even possible and he
happens to have seizures - so this
seizure would be an indication that he's
not following you know it's kind of
getting out of that metabolic zone that
is sort of optimal for the management of
the cancer so he's called it like a
blessing that the that the epilepsy was
sort of helped him with cancer
management because when he got a seizure
he it sort of was an indication or an
aura before having a seizure sort of
like a pre seizure event and that he had
a protocol that he could quickly
administer things like magnesium
chloride and or you know exhaustive
ketones to quickly get him back into a
state of ketosis - I don't know if
you're an athlete or kind of managing
some kind of pathology but occasional
cheat meal for performance I think is
totally fine the problem that I run into
if I do a cheat meal like I just felt
like a refeed and I like eating a
ketogenic diet so I tend not to cheat
that much what I'll do is sometimes just
eat more of the same foods but
occasionally I'll go out for sushi and
have rice and and some other things and
what I notice when I do that is that I
get hungry at night so I will wake up
instead of waking at my normal time I'll
wake up
an hour two or three earlier and just be
really hungry because the carbs that I
ate the night before if I cheat us
usually in the evening get what is
likely a an insulin dump that makes me
hypoglycemic in the middle of the night
and you know if I don't have the ketones
there if the the insulin shuts off my
own ketone production that my body
senses that hypoglycemia and I feel I
wake up with the shakes and I feel get
that hypoglycemic effect at night and
that happens you know that that's what I
notice so my suggestion would be if
you're going to do a cheat meal and you
want to if you're doing nutritional
ketosis do a slow carb approach and add
sufficient amounts of fats and I think
you'll get a better response I don't
know why you know if you do a cheat me I
guess you're just trying to restore your
glycogen levels or kind of reset your
system I think you'll get a better
restoration of liver and muscle glycogen
and you'll get probably a better
hormonal response in terms of restoring
some of the hormones that you think may
be suppressed so t4 to t3 conversions or
that sort of thing if you sort of
balance the meal out and just don't go
crazy eating you know keep in mind that
a cheat meal can do an incredible amount
of quote-unquote damage in regards to
facking so it should be a calculated
sort of meal and you should have cap it
off and do some you know you might not
just bring a scale with you but just
figure out you know how many calories
you're gonna E I'm not going to go over
like 400 grams of carbs or something
like that because I've seen people a
thousand grams of carbs in one sitting
and that's no lie so uh so if you tend
to go out of control I need a big bowl
of and just you know eat a huge bowl of
fries or just go out of control or
chocolate cake or something like that
one strategy that I've done is if I'm
going to go out and have sushi for
example or
have some kind of meal that's
carbohydrates I'll have a big bowl of
soup before and that will sort of send a
signal to my brain your your brain is
pretty good at sensing the amount of
volume and weight of food that's in your
stomach so if you send that signal to
your brain before you actually start
eating the food that'll kind of cap off
the amount of calories that you can
you'll comfortably be able to eat so the
next question comes from blue light diet
so I assume it's the author of this book
or website or whatever so and in caps he
says explain this tonic guys you know
ketogenic diets have no metabolic
advantage as shown from the juicy study
so I've gotten a lot of emails about
this and you know I don't know I know
the new C is doing a lot of really great
funding a lot of great research and I
know one of the studies may have
surfaced at least in a in abstract form
at a conference in the form of a poster
so from my understanding there's really
nothing to explain
if calories are completely you know
isocaloric between the diets sure that
makes sense to me at least that there's
not going to be through the metabolic
advantage you know when I think of the
ketogenic diet and when one sustains
nutritional ketosis for some time it's
actually enhancing metabolic efficiency
there's some theories out there that if
you follow ketogenic diet it will
increase brown fat accumulation which
could you know allow one to burn off
more calories you want to lose weight on
a ketogenic diet you simply have to
calorie restrict that's sort of
thermodynamics right just like a
standard diet so the advantage of and I
hope this comes out of the research I'm
sure it well the advantage from my
perspective of a ketogenic diet is that
your appetite is suppressed
so you naturally eat less
so if you're you don't have these big
postprandial blood-glucose excursions
and trigger a hypoglycemic response
you're not it's not going to trigger
cravings so I've seen in myself and I
think that's the main advantage of the
diet you know if you want to hear like a
counter-argument to what was sort of
presented as no metabolic advantage from
the ketogenic diet if you want to hear a
counter-argument to this there's a
10-minute youtube video that you can
read from dr. David look ludwig or dr.
fineman's response to that so there's
more data to emerge but we need to we'll
leave it you know at that for now and
until more the studies start to surface
so hamilton are blair it's dumb in a
podcast with Ron Patrick you alluded to
the fact that dairy doesn't do well for
you and that you have a mild allergy
t-nuts what is your primary sources of
fat for a modified ketogenic diet MT T's
coconut cream milk oil butter so my
primary fat sources are eggs and I'm
kind of picky about the eggs that I get
I try to source out you know local eggs
and it from free-range chickens avocados
olive oil
yes MCT oil about a third of my calories
come from fat calories come from MCT oil
or coconut oil both combinations do
fatty meats and fatty fish for sure and
I do I don't do well with a lot of nuts
but I do okay with like maybe a half cup
of macadamia nuts per day and that's a
pretty big amount of fat so yeah I can't
think of any other kind of fat sources
but you could pretty much fill the gap
in calories with egg yolks and avocados
and
and especially if you're sourcing out
fatty meats or poultry with the skin on
it
so Damian Matthews writes I listened but
don't remember if you discuss metformin
or methylene blue or other non-food
substances he's exploring for longevity
though methylene blue yeah I know a
little bit about that but I know a
little bit more about metformin so
there's a couple interesting studies
sort of ongoing being set up now
actually the mile study which stands for
metformin in longevity study is a pilot
study to examine the effective meant for
min treatment on sort of the biology of
Aging in humans it's really looking at
the how metformin
can restore the gene expression profile
of older adults with impaired so older
adults that tend to be impaired in
glucose tolerance to that of young
healthy subjects so how does the
metformin alter that gene expression
profile really interesting questions we
don't have answers yet I know there's a
University of Alabama's doing a
multi-year trial on metformin and
longevity I think there's a you know
maybe a couple other studies that are
being developed now that you might be
able to find on clinical trials cup so
it does appear that metformin has a
calorie restriction mimetic effect in
regards to signaling so it lowers blood
glucose it suppresses it lowers insulin
a little bit it we it lowers glucose in
those that have high blood glucose and
in those that don't have elevated blood
glucose it lowers it but not that much
very little it does I found myself and
in others and I think in animal models
as showing this to there's an elevation
of ketones and I think that elevation in
ketones is
further enhance if you're on a ketogenic
diet suggesting that it may be enhancing
fatty acid oxidation in the liver
metformin is pretty powerful activator
of amp kinase and it may lower and poor
signaling you know etc etc so it does
all these things are things at calorie
restriction do and we think that the
benefits of calorie restriction are
likely mediated by some of the things
that I mentioned and undoubtedly there's
many other things that that are also
happening there was a study done in rats
and it's important to you know
acknowledge the type of strain because
there's strain differences and we
realized this when we work with
different animals
these were Fisher 344 rats and there's a
study showing metformin supplementation
on the lifespan of this rat model and no
significant lifespan extension was
observed with metformin supplementation
at least at the dose that they used in
the study and I have to go back and look
at the study when we give metformin
Ilana some of the studies just kind of
inject metformin is like a metformin
hydrochloride solution we actually I
think it's important to mix it in with
the food and that's what we do with our
study so when you know the standardized
standardized dose obviously from a
scientist standpoint it makes sense to
just kind of go in there with a syringe
and give X amount of metformin you know
intraperitoneal E or sub-q da Liang so
you know exactly how much we're doing
but the the rodents pretty much eat the
same amount of food give or take a few
grams every day so we actually mix the
metformin into the food so when the
animals eat the food they will get the
metformin we think when they need it
right so the metformin helps to kind of
normalize blood glucose in response to a
meal and I think other investigators may
do kind of an injection of the metformin
or they put it in
water but we think it's important to
sort of give the metformin while you're
giving calories that would increase
blood glucose or insulin so it helps to
mitigate that that effect so in this
rodent studies I saw no extension of a
lifespan with metformin my concern with
metformin is that the side effects for
long-term use so I've used it sort of in
myself and I'm like the effects of it I
think it it generally has like a little
bit of a calming effect above two grams
starts to give some GI discomfort one of
the side effects that I've observed with
metformin is that it caused I guess we'd
call it a photo reaction or photo
dermatitis on my wrist and you know why
is it doing that it's that's something I
don't know I've kind of looked into and
so my wrists are kind of the dermis of
both my wrists are kind of messed up
because I use lifting straps and an in
the passage kind of handle a lot of
weight with doing shrugs like and I've
damaged the underlying dermis and that
area can it would get eczema which I did
when I was following a high carb diet it
would occur in those areas so those
areas are just really sensitive areas of
my body and when I was on metformin and
I think it may have accumulated my
system and I went outside that those
areas would be highly reactive to to
light and it would start to sort of get
hives in that area so I stopped
metformin and then I transitioned to
Berber in and that completely went away
so admit Foreman also has the issue that
a lot of GI discomfort with metformin
and there's also some data to indicate
that it could reduce the transport and
utilization of b12 so you might want to
supplement b12 with that but when it
comes to using metformin for longevity
I don't I think the jury's still out and
we need to look at that and it's
something we actually may do in the lab
in our aged animal model but for
longevity of things that I do you know
are the big the big things obviously
you're just strength training you know
muscle biggest factor of aging the
biggest consequence I guess you call it
pathological consequence of aging would
be a loss of skeletal muscle so the most
important thing to do would be intense
you know heavy weight training a minimum
of twice a week to help preserve as much
muscle as possible and things that
enhance our mitochondrial health and
vitality and that would be nutritional
ketosis intermittent fasting not a big
fan of endurance exercise but I do go
for walks a couple times a week and then
eat that we need to force myself to do
this but I think high-intensity interval
training done two or three times a week
would be would be optimal for getting
along deputy effects so I just have not
been able to get myself motivated to do
high-intensity interval training the
next question comes from Josh Brackett
does the ketogenic diet can I use it for
glycolytic training Muay Thai question I
get quite often the combination of a
diet and training together produces in
adaptation so what you're really going
for yes you can use a ketogenic diet for
glycolytic training but you have to
train for that you have to sort of do
the training and follow the diet and
overtime and time being like over three
months um I'm convinced that your body
most people's metabolic physiology will
adapt to a ketogenic diet you know with
like lytic training and you know if we
talk about maybe losing some of that
that quick firing of the type to fast
twitch low oxidative fibers you know we
want to keep that power that strength
you can if you're supplementing with
things like creatine and if you're
eating red meat I think it may be a
little more important if you're on a
ketogenic diet to supplement with a good
creatine product created monohydrate we
find not all people will be able to
adapt to the diet so I think that's kind
of important but I think most
importantly it's to give it an honest
try you've got to give it about three to
six months and you may just shift to a
low carb for a while with some ketone
supplementation and before you actually
try a ketogenic diet and so so that may
be why I like short term ketogenic diet
studies on performance show a decrease
right because there's a lot of the
low-carb studies out there that are
quote-unquote ketogenic they just don't
have the athletes fault diet long enough
to be sufficiently keto adapted to to
really get the benefits of diet so you
know Geoff bollock Bullock and his
faster study did athletes that had been
adapted to a ketogenic diet for like a
year or more if you look at their fat
oxidation rates during training these
are endurance and not not like leg
training but they're burning you know
two times roughly two times more fat and
that's that's preserving glycogen so in
the context of glycolytic training if
your body is fat adapted and and the
athletes were burning conservatively
more conservatively more fat just at
rest the the practical advantage there
is that you're preserving muscle
glycogen for the event Gerard a Dawson
the third ask what is it like to be an
academic who also makes serious weight
training a big part of your life and how
do you do
to pursue how do these two pursuits
complement or complicate each other it's
a good question they complement each
other because the lessons that I learned
from training you know weight training
over the years the first book I read was
Arnold the education of a bodybuilder I
think I was like 13 or 14 years old and
that book probably saved me in some way
because at the time I was like a
horrible student you know it just kind
of did what I needed to do to get passed
in academia and when I was sitting in
class the the only thing I wanted to do
is leave class you know I could just
think about getting home and just doing
you know just not being in school so
training really serious weight training
at the time which I didn't in my teen
years it really I guess groomed to my my
mind and my body to for for being
resilient and kind of understanding that
it really takes hard work to advance
because when I started training I was
like making no progress at all I mean it
had to be a hard training coupled with
fortified with a big game plan so I
became like what I would call an
obsessive planner I would carry this
little book with me and write down
specifically what I was going to do and
I did that I have training journals
sitting in my office right now training
journals from when I was 14 years old a
very detailed like sets and reps and I
can look I can go back and look at each
of those workouts and actually remember
it being downstairs in my parents
basement gym and remember it and that
and I sort of parlayed that mindset
being very structured and disciplined
from weight training and it took a
couple years by eventually
by the time I was 17 or 18 I applied
that to my academic pursuits and I was
more motivated to do so because my the
classes that I was taking were a little
more challenging like honors biology
classes and things where I was learning
about diet I was learning about a little
bit about nutrition and so in in
academia and for being a scientist the
sort of rigorous planning note-taking
self-evaluation being honest and
critical of myself I think really helps
out a lot so you know if I'm completely
honest now though I don't I would not
want to be sort of as big and strong or
into lifting as I was when I was younger
so generally I think serious weight
training when it when it comes to
bodybuilding powerlifting powerlifting
in a very elite level it's kind of an
unhealthy sport so so my folk is
primarily as I've been getting older is
longevity and your priorities change
when you get older so it's not to be as
big and strong as humanly possible
because that involves pretty much
non-stop eating in my case because I've
kind of an ectomorph ik body so you're
asking so how do the two pursuits
complement one another or complicate one
another complicate so yeah it's so the
pursuit of size and strength really
contradicts what we want to go after for
longevity right for longevity we want to
pretty much eat the minimal amount of
calories that we need to sustain whereas
surplus calories can lead to you know
the activation of certain pathways and
genes and igf-1 that could contribute to
aging or an accelerated path to
age-related chronic diseases and maybe
even cancer right so there's that
balance
so I want to maintain a lot of the
strength that I have been able to accrue
for my earlier years but be able to do
it in a way and maintain that line such
that that size and strength without
compromising my health and that's and
right now I'm just kind of in the
maintenance phase but I still make
training a priority regardless no matter
how busy things get in the lab at work
with teaching or travel or whatever you
know I make it a priority and I think
it's important to be a lot more flexible
in the way that you get you get your
workouts in so be creative my time is
much more limited so you know be able to
do a workout on the fly I'm air we were
doing it actually on our way to Asia my
wife and I things are before you travel
you just kind of bogged down was trying
to get everything done two or three days
out and worked out for like three days
like at all
I was completely sort of immobile behind
my desk and we're on the plane and it
was like a 14 no I think a 17-hour
flight and and I had to get up and walk
around and and she got up too and we
basically I started doing squats with
her on my back in the middle the aisle
these are things that I do now I will do
like push-ups with her on my back like
if I don't have access to a gym I will
go find a tree you know if you're really
motivated and it's part of who you are
and what you do if there's no excuse
that you can't fit in a workout Daniel
by rachanna asks ok your thoughts on
John Kieffer's carb nite or carb
backloading so yeah this is so carb
backloading is actually really effective
for gaining size and strength and I did
that probably a lot in the early 2000s
it was something that I was already
doing
yeah years ago it's important
now I understand and appreciate the
importance of titrating the levels
of carbohydrate to the individuals and
it's not I know it shouldn't be in an
all-you-can-eat sort of free-for-all
after your after your workout I don't
care how intense your workout is that's
not going to be optimal it's not going
to be productive so you want to prevent
your postprandial glucose levels from
getting too high right so you want to
optimize your recovery to optimize
glycogen restoration you want to prevent
your glucose levels from getting above
say for me it's about 130 to 120 230 and
I find that I can if I do carb
backloading which I I took a little bit
of time out and tried it a year or two
ago and I was getting a lot of questions
on this
I could gradually sort of amp ramp up my
carbs to about 350 after a hard workout
and that's my glucose would start to
climb to about you know about 140 but I
wanted to keep it below that and also
the types of carbohydrates I consumed
were pretty important too but I think no
more even a large individual that was
way too much I think I could get the
same effect by a hundred to 20 grams of
carbs for carb backloading it's really
important if you're going to do this on
it on a daily basis or weekly or
whatever it's important to acknowledge
sort of all the negative things that can
result from hitting your body with a
massive glucose load and doing that
immediately after you've done a lot of
damage to the body where you've sort of
stimulated the muscle in a way where you
have a lot of breakdown a lot of
inflammation
if you throw a lot of glucose at it it's
gonna the consequences are not going to
be good and we know that when your
glucose level gets above a hundred and
forty milligrams per deciliter that can
cause irreversible bay
Celt lost so your beta cells are the
cells that produce insulin so if you
routinely get your glucose levels above
that you essentially have beta cell
burnout over time so that's been shown
that's published there's a couple
articles you know you can find on that
you can get potentially you know nerve
damage with with that sort of high
quickest levels and especially in people
that are a little more older and insulin
resistance the cancer rates increase if
glucose spikes above say a hundred and
sixty milligrams per deciliter over time
so if you're getting kind of 160
milliliter milligrams per deciliter
spikes in your glucose by doing these
big refeeds it's you could potentially
increase your rates of cancer stroke
risk is increased by about 25% for every
1 millimolar rise in post-meal blood
sugars so that has been documented so
that's important so that's 18 milligrams
per deciliter for every sort of rise so
you need to consider these things the
health consequences to these big
illnesses of sugar so I've used this
approach and I think it produces good
results like I said for me kind of a I'm
over 100 kilograms and I didn't find
that I need any more than a hundred to
200 grams of carbohydrates post-workout
and any more than that and 10 what
happens is that you just tend to spill
over and you just kind of hold a lot of
water after you're not effectively
storing the glucose as glycogen it just
gets into your your it just fills over
so a slow car approach to back loading
is probably the best approach so if you
do this slowly you know add the
carbohydrates in and do you look like
lower glycemic carbohydrates to do that
the last question I'd like to address is
that about the safety of the ketone salt
products on the market specifically the
DL beta-hydroxybutyrate salts that are a
part of the key genex product pruvit
keto OS keto sports Aikido kena
foreverGreen sells key topia these are
all products that I've used and I like
and there was a podcast Dave Asprey and
Ben Greenfield had doctored each on and
he talked about the potential dangers of
the DL beta-hydroxybutyrate salts and
even about acetoacetate so our number
one concern when we do research is
safety so the FDA really decides and of
what's safe as it moves to market and
not us we screen all forms of exhaustion
as ketones in our lab including you know
the d beta hydroxy butyrate the racemic
compounds and acetyl acetate esters so
it happened to be dr. greening grabbers
ester developed at Case Western that we
used for our CNS oxygen toxicity seizure
studies because beta hydroxy butyrate
esters are the D and the intimate beta
hydroxy butyrate did not work whereas
the brooding grabber ester elevated both
beta hydroxy butyrate
n acetyl acetate so dr. beaches opinion
is at the DL beta hydroxy butyrate
because it's racemic it has a lot of
problems potential problems regarding
safety that specifically that racemic
compounds there's a lot of inherent
dangers in using them it's important to
note and that many drugs are on market
our racemic and that would include
things like adderall ephedrine ephedrine
hydrochloride in pseudoephedrine
ibuprofen is racemic and these things
are proven safe and beta-hydroxybutyrate
it actually has a naturally-occurring
isomerase for the interconversion from
the L to the D form and there's a
mountain of studies you know that
clearly showed that DL
beta-hydroxybutyrate
suppresses seizures inhibits cancer
suppresses reactive oxygen species
oxidative stress protects the liver
promotes wound healing reduces
inflammation protects against
hypoglycemia and stroke is protective
against leukodystrophy a number of rare
disorders so I'm just kind of looking
through all the publications I have in
my file here and these effects would not
be observed if the L beta hydroxy
butyrate was dangerous or ineffective
which was you know proposed and
discussed on the podcast and you also
need to consider that approximately ten
million doses of DL beta-hydroxybutyrate
salts have been consumed worldwide from
the pruvit product to forever grain to
keto kina sells quite well and you know
at least ten million doses I believe
have been sold and there's you know a
little if any I don't think any adverse
medical side effects have been recorded
with this just besides diarrhea and of
loose stools if the jockey gets too high
and I know some individuals that are
dosing really high if the DL
beta-hydroxybutyrate was toxic
it would have been reported you know by
all these people using it and also be
reported in the medical literature for
the use of you know to treat a variety
of different medical conditions and keep
in mind that they're using the pure
sodium beta-hydroxybutyrate
which you know there's a lot of
discussion about sodium being dangerous
and we won't think that's the case
that's kept at a particular level and
nots you know anything is toxic if it
gets too high but it's also pretty
important to balance out
beta-hydroxybutyrate
and to spread it across various minerals
so they have a beta-hydroxybutyrate salt
product that has potassium calcium
magnesium and sodium together with the
ideal I've really gotten hundreds of
emails from from people that have given
me tremendous feedback on the ketone
salts and feedback on performance and
feedback or therapeutic use of ketone
salts I don't advise using ketone soles
for therapeutic purposes because
clinical trials need to be done but that
does not stop people from using them and
and parents you know reporting that that
their their child is now able to achieve
nutritional ketosis and getting many
benefits so I think taking up a lot of
time here and we've covered a lot of
ground
probably more ground than we need it to
if you have any I've enjoyed kind of
looking through all these questions I
haven't looked through all of them yet
but I look through about 80% of them I
think they're excellent questions thank
you for listening and I look forward to
maybe being on again and handling more
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five below Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles
that I have read and that I've shared
with my close friends for instance and
it's very short it's just a little tiny
bite of goodness before you head off for
the weekend
so if you want to receive that check it
out just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by wealth
front and this is a very unique sponsor
wealth front is a massively disruptive
in a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash Tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com4
slash tim that is less than five dollars
a month to invest a thirty thousand
dollar account for instance now normally
when I was
around the shows because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if
you decide to open an account but just
start with seeing the portfolio that
they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire and
wealthfront calm forward-slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of this episode is brought
to you by Vimeo specifically a new
offering called Vimeo business I've done
a lot of collaboration with these guys
Vimeo business has all of the prior
benefits of Vimeo Pro including VIP
support whether you make videos for a
living run your own company like yours
truly or simply want to amp up your
video marketing video business is here
to help they have more than 280 million
creators and viewers worldwide and Vimeo
business makes it easier to share your
videos with a global audience and
connect with professional video makers
to bring your stories to life so if you
need assistance it's there you can also
upload up to five terabytes and store
your videos in one secure place you can
add up to 10 team members to your
account for easy collaboration and
gather feedback with seamless review
tools you can add clickable calls to
action and perhaps most interesting to
me capture email addresses directly in
the player this can help you generate
leads and drive conversion for whatever
you are trying to optimize say for a
newsletter or in fact a sales page of
some type video business helps you
optimize your videos by tracking viewer
engagement and drop-off so you can then
modify your approach or creative moving
forward and improve it and it connects
to Google Analytics for even more
insights let's check it out go to Vimeo
com forward slash Tim 10 to save 10% on
Vimeo business that's vimeo.com
slash t IM
zero